you're about to enjoy a free preview
from the bob's burgers movie
well that's the first time an
exterminator said he's gonna pray for us
that's okay right that's not a bad sign
no
what you're doing gene i'm making an
instrument out of spoons and a napkin
holder and dreams and magic obviously
tina how's the burger bob it's okay i
put an egg on it why is dad making a
burger at 8 a.m is he on british time
he's making it to bring to mr dowling at
the bank we have a meeting this morning
and we're gonna ask for an extension on
a loan payment oh fun then we really
really need to get that extension all
the restaurant equipment is wrapped up
in that loan so you're giving him a
burger well i mean we can't give him
money tina cause we don't have any
pretty much how about you playing some
of this
what to scare him no to enchant him bob
you know i love this bring him a burger
idea but isn't it a little early to be
making it i mean our appointment isn't
for a while this is a practice burger
why are you whispering i don't want it
to hear him feel bad okay
wait um what nothing what you're great
that feels nice i know i know don't rub
my sesame seeds off i won't don't worry
they're a cute couple uh i give them a
year uh i'm gonna make another practice
burger and uh i'm gonna try not to think
too much about how much it's riding on
today maybe i should put two eggs on it
hey this could be your burger of the day
you can call it you keep your sunny side
up and your cloudy side down stay
positive bobby things are gonna be okay
parker right it's a little long how
about mr gracie well better get going
only one more week of school and then
i'm summer tina and big things are
coming for summertina big things like
that heat rash you get sometimes bigger
summer louise might be making some moves
that are pretty big too maybe i don't
know don't worry about it all right fine
sorry summer jeans gonna be topless 24 7
and doing a lot of this
watch out for the messed up sidewalk
thank you
[Music]
every day we come downstairs unlock the
door and turn the sign to open
open
here's another day i give myself a
little diarrhea from the worry and the
stressing and the hope and
you should think about
those fears
send us on our merry way hey have
yourselves a pleasant day we'll come
back here he'll come with sir we'll hug
and kiss and get to oh bobby i like what
i'm hearing
diary is fine but no sense fear and
when you have that justin's optimistic
spirit it's gonna be the sunny side of
summer of our lives
[Applause]
every time i see him oh my heart does a
crazy little dance something like
looks good and i want for him to kiss me
and then walk away so i can see what's
shaking in the backside of his pants
i think that this is real
what i feel and if he could feel it too
well then that would be ideal so i wanna
make this thing legit i'm gonna put a
ring on it but not a ring cause that's
great gray i mean we're only in eighth
grade i'll do the thing eighth graders
do when you like like me and i like like
you put something special on a train and
give it to him and explain i'd like for
you to be my summer boyfriend
you'll say yes and then to seal it shake
your rear end
and it's gonna
be the sunny side of summer of my life
each and every
day i want to sing i want to play
play this left anything i made it and
it's gonna revolutionize american pop
music each and every day
i just think i'm pretty great
yup that's right
no big deal
i'm not hiding what i feel about some
things
on my mind and if they're holding me
behind
keeping me
feeling small
though they actually make me tall hope
they don't hear me talking about them
don't know what i am without them but
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
summer
it will be great it's gonna work
[Music]
yes
[Music]
no huh i'm sorry extension denied you
have seven days to make your payment or
we'll repossess your restaurant
equipment seven days possess uh
equipment like haunted i brought you a
burger oh no thanks i'm trying to eat
less meat oh my god i'm going to close
out the file and uh your faces are
making me
sad
so if you could go oh my face and can
you take the um
there's fries in there you want the
fries typing till you're gone typing
till you're gone
and that is the breakthrough we've been
looking for it hurts my teeth somehow
also who's we the band our
underappreciated but highly influential
band the itty bitty ditty committee that
we're in with my sisters and recorder
bad boy peter pescadero oh right we were
in a band and we went with that name yes
and we were just waiting to discover our
sound and i'm sure you agree that i
found it
oh gotta get ya i'm gonna get checked
come on nevermind i'm too high sorry
sorry sorry ah i'm gonna do it i'm gonna
walk right over there and i'm gonna do
it i'm not gonna do it i am gonna do it
here i go nope going back over here
can't do it yes i can yes i can oh take
my penis area nope not the right time
stand down soldier ready go
louise come do a dead match drop ooh
that's over there and i'm over here but
thank you she's scared
uh no i'm not i mean i'm scared of how
comfortable i am over here she's afraid
her hat will fall off
you're afraid my hat will fall off so
gotcha good one i mean kinda i don't
know why she still wears that thing it's
like she's five oh boy
[Music]
what'd you say did you just use the b
word uh i'm pretty sure she said lady i
heard rabies well
you babies
what's going on over here a little
conflict
stupid bank sonny side up more like
crappy side up it's gonna be okay bob
bob do you think he remembers that i
ordered the burger
um
yeah
your sidewalk's getting worse uh-huh i
saw someone trip hey how are you guys
going to celebrate getting that load
extension should i get some t-shirts
made i'd wear one we didn't get the
extensions heavy what but you made a
burger he's eating that's me teddy okay
he's eating rest me bob calm down seven
days we can do this all we have to do is
sell enough burgers in seven days to pay
the bank which is a lot ah well that's
not that much right we can do it hey
there's gonna be more business down to
wonder wharf because of the octo
warfiverssery oh yeah the octo-worthy
more foot traffic uh yeah that's that's
true and feet have mouths mouths that we
could put burgers in right bob yeah feet
have mouths feet mouths
there he is see doesn't it feel good to
be a little hopeful instead of being
scary and shouty and making people feel
nervous to ask about their order yeah it
does a little bit it's gonna
be the
sunny side up come on
wow
[Music]
oh my god
see what happens next order the entire
movie the bob's burgers movie now
available
you